in this video we will study about the
process of spermatogenesis
spermatogenesis is the production of
mature male gametes which are known as
sperms
about 200 to 300 million sperms are
produced daily in the male gonads known
as the testes
these immature sperms also undergo a
process of maturation in the epidermis
to form the mature sperms
for a better understanding of this topic
make sure to watch our video on the male
reproductive system
as we discuss the anatomy of the testes
in the male reproductive system
the testes contains numerous pipe-like
structures known as seminiferous tubules
the seminiferous tubules have a central
lumen
and outer wall
the wall of the seminiferous tubule is
the main site for the production of
sperms
now let's look at a closer view of the
section of the wall of seminiferous
tubule
as we can see the wall of the
seminiferous tubule contains numerous
type of cells and one of them are the
primary germ cells
the primary germ cells transform through
various stages of development and
finally form immature sperms known as
spermatids
now let's talk about the process of
smartogenesis in a big detail
the process of matteogenesis is divided
into two phases the first is the
spermatocytogenesis
in which one germ cell divides into four
precursor gametes known as spermatids
these methods are immature sperms
the second phase is the spermyogenesis
in which no further cell division occurs
but the immature sperms go through the
process of maturation and
differentiation to form mature sperms
so now let's talk about the series of
cell division that occurs in the first
phase of somatogenesis we start with the
primary germ cells known as the primary
smart ammonium type a which are found in
the wall of the seminiferous tubules the
main job of primary smataconium type a
is to divide into two types of cells the
first is the type b primary smatoconium
the type b's matagonium auto reproduce
and maintain the number of the primary
smatagonium type a
the first division in the series
matteogenesis is a mitosis which gives
rise to an intermediate stage known as
primary somatocyte the primary
somatocyte are diploid cells maintaining
the number of chromosomes
in the second division the primary
somatocyte go through the first phase of
the meiosis and divide their chromosomal
material into half to give rise to
secondary spermatocytes which are
haploid cells
in the last stage the secondary
spermatocytes again go through the
process of meiosis ii and maintain the
chromosomal number they give rise to
four immature sperms known as spermatids
looking at the wall of the seminiferous
tubule in a bit detail the primary
smatagonium are located in the basal
layer of the wall of seminiferous tubule
and in the center you can see the
various divisions from primary
somatosite till the spermatids during
all these cell divisions the sertoli
cells give support and nutrition to the
developing gametes so now we know that
one germ cell gives rise to four
spermatids
but matters are immature sperm cells
incapable of fertilization and they
contain numerous cell bodies like golgi
body centrioles and mitochondria the
spermatids undergo through the process
of sponiogenesis which is second phase
of somatogenesis to form mature sperms
the process of spermiogenesis is
basically divided into four phases
which converts a immature sperm into a
mature sperm
the first is the golgi phase where the
golgi body present in the spermatid
forms the enzymes of the acrosome
the second is the acrosomal phase where
the formed acrosome condenses around the
nucleus to form the cap
the third is the tail phase where the
centriole present in the spermatid forms
the tail of the sperm and the last is
the maturation phase where the spermatid
loses the excess cytoplasm and forms a
mature sperm
but the mature sperms are still
non-motile
as we know the process of
spermatogenesis runs in the wall of the
seminiferous tubule the mature sperms
are then released in the lumen of the
seminiferous tubule through a process
called permeation
the sperms then spend a few days in the
epidermis and gain motility the motile
sperms are thus capable of fertilization
so this was all about the process of
spermatogenesis i hope you found this
video helpful thank you so much for
watching this video like our channel on
youtube for all the upcoming videos and
make sure to like our channel on
facebook for flash cards and upcoming
notifications